Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P here is a really good
question that many of you have written in
with about the telepathic declassification
of documents. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Hey, David,
enjoy the show. Hey, what would happen if Biden
thought about reclassifying the documents?
Right. If a sitting president can do that, right?
Speaker 1: Yeah. No, it's. I get that it's a joke,
but it's absolutely a real thing. If Trump
can think about documents and declassify them,
then Biden can think about documents and classify
them. And thus it becomes completely indivisible
one way or the other. Because no matter what,
at any point, any document could be classified
or declassified based on what the current
president has thought about. It's absurd. These
people are nuts, guys. These people do telepathic
declassification. Give me a break. It's pathetic.
We have a great bonus show for you today. Liz
Cheney, Republican Congresswoman Liz Cheney,
outgoing because she was defeated in her
Republican primary in Wyoming. Liz Cheney
says that if Trump is the nominee in 2024,
she will leave the Republican Party. And she
will campaign for Democrats. What? Yes, we will
discuss that on today's bonus show. Secondly,
80% of American voters want Congress to enact
national paid family leave. And this is another
one of these examples where we supposedly have
the will of the people reflected in the elected
officials that are voted on by the general public.
And yet the general public is very far to the left
of our elected officials. And this is another
issue where that is the case. And thirdly,
everything going terribly for Rudy Giuliani, who
has now been ordered to pay his ex-wife $225,000
or face jail time. Rudy is claiming that
as a result of all of this legal trouble
in which he finds himself, he doesn't have the
money. He says he's increasingly without money.
Is that even true? We don't know. We'll talk
about it and more on today's bonus show. You
can sign up at join Packman dot com to get instant
access to the bonus show. We will see you then. Or
otherwise. Right back here tomorrow. Michael Cohen
scheduled to join us later this week about his new
book. I do want to hear from him about some of
these latest. You know what? When the pictures
came out of Trump's Mar a Lago, I thought
Michael Cohen would know. What does Trump's
office normally look like? Is it normally the
mess that it appeared to be in? The pictures? I
have so many things to talk to him about. He has a
super interesting new book that will be later this
week. But for now, sign up at Joint Pack Uncommon.
We'll see you back here on the podcast tomorrow.